あまり難しい話ではなくて
もうすごい簡単な単純なところをお話しさせていただきます
えっと ちょっと仏教から見れば失礼なタイトルですけどね
まあ世渡り術だから 仏教の人々が聞いたら冗談じゃないでしょうと言うかもしれませんけど
でもまあ一応私が決めたタイトルだからしょうがないんですけど
あまりたくさん情報を私はまとめてないんですから
これはできるだけ実践的に具体的にお話しなくちゃいけないことなんですね
ですから 途中で皆様方も自分の人生の中でいろいろトラブルに出会ったとことかね
人生負けたこととか 悔しくてたまらなかったこととか
そういういろいろ出来事
具体的なところを途中で構いませんから教えていただけると
まあもう過去の話ですけど
それはね まあそれでもその場合はこういう風にした方が良かったんではないかというブッダの智慧をね
教えてあげることはできますので
できるだけ具体的に実践的に話を進めるようにと
努力しましょう で まずは
この前ももう今はほとんど私の話はリピートなんです
私のもう寿命だなと思ってます
今までもずっとリピートはしなかったんで
ずっと一回喋ったものは二度と喋れないというふうな
えらいもう高慢でやっていましたけど
で 今はなんか全部リピートになっているんです
もうちょっと自分にとっては面白くないんですけど
で まあ残り話はまだいっぱいありますが
どうもまだまだ難しすぎて語れないところいっぱいありますけどね
ですから まあこれもリピートなんですけどね
本当は まあ寿命だからしょうがないですよね
で この前いつかわかりません
覚えてないんだけど 言った物語
エピソードはありますね
ある日 あるバラモンのバラモンと言ったっても誰かわかりませんが
あるバラモンの人がお釈迦様を招待したんです
お釈迦様は何のことなく
はい 分かりましたということで
その人の家に行ったんですね
ですから 出家の方々にこのお食事などを作ってお布施するのは普通常識だから
でお釈迦様はその家に行ったら
その人はお釈迦様にお布施する気持ちは全くないんです
かなりお釈迦様のことを怒っているんです
自分の宗教と違う宗教を教えてるんだから
それで自分の仲間はどんどん仏教徒になっていくしね
それには結構機嫌が悪かった人なんですね
それでその人の家にそういうことを全然気にしないで家に行ったんですね
行ったらこの人はもう自分知ってるだけの全ての言葉を選んでお釈迦様を叱ったんです
侮辱したんです けなしちゃったんです
ありとあらゆる言葉で
だから自分の家に呼ばれて
お釈迦様が座ってから
まあ言いたい放題 もうとんでもない失礼な言葉を使ったりしてお釈迦様を叱ってるんですよ
でお釈迦様はじーっと何の返事もしないで聞いているんです
聞いていて まあいくら叱っても一方的に叱るともう電池切れちゃうんですよ
人が怒ったら あなた何ですか？と言ったら
もうあんたは何よと反論しちゃうと
もうエネルギーが出てきて
もう百年でも喧嘩できますよ
で それでお釈迦様はそういうことはなくて
ただじーっと聞いているんですね
そうすると 本人のエネルギーは全部切れちゃったんです
もうこちらからもう反論ないんだから
言うことは全部終わったんです
それで終わりましたかと
終わったの？と言ったんです
終わった もうそれ以上言うことないんだから
で あの 私にちょっとした例え思い浮かんだと
で まああなた偉い人だから
まあいろいろ立派な親戚とかね
たくさんいるでしょう
いますよと そういう人々にこのパーティーで接待しようと思って
あなたはものすごいごちそうする
そういうことをしたことはありますか？と
まあしょっちゅうありますよと
その場合は もしその約束した親戚たちが
友人たちが来なかったら
あのごちそうをどうしますかね
それは当たり前 私と私の家内と子どもたちで食べますよ
だったら まあそうですか
で 私は考えたのは あなた
私を招待して 今 叱り 侮辱というね
ごちそうしたんだけど
残念ながら私はいただけませんね
それは一つも だからどうぞ自分と自分の奥さんと子どもたちにと一緒に味わってくださいと言ってお釈迦様が帰ったんです
だからお釈迦様の言い返しは
あれよりはもう何万倍も強いんですよ
言い返しちゃったんです
もうこれに応えられない
だからお釈迦様に馬鹿と言ったならば
自分と自分の奥さんと子どもたちになっちゃうでしょうね
馬鹿という言葉じゃないんです
ものすごい貶し言葉なんですよ
言ったのは 死んでしまえと言ったならば
それは自分と自分の奥さんと子どもたちで
だからその技なんですよ
ただ もう人に叱られてもニコニコと聞いていると
なんだかちょっとまあまあニコニコ聞いてるのはいいんですけど
ちょっとそれだけで十分かなという気持ちもあるでしょうね
そうでもないんですよ
何か解決方法はあるんです
あのバラモンの口をあれっきりでもう止まってもらうんだから
あれでもうあの人 二度と他の人を叱らないだろうと思いますけどね
ああいうことが起きちゃったら
で それでお釈迦様のそういうこのものすごいこの
鋭い生き方があったんです
だから この我々 そこそこの俗人たちが
我々一般人が思い描くような人ではないんですよ
私たちは自分好き勝手な宗教家
ブッダ もうイエス様云々と言っちゃうと
まあ良いことばっかしでとか思っちゃいますけど
まあ誰にでも頭を下げて
親切で謙虚でとかね そんな偏見的な見方っていうのはおかしいでしょうに
それじゃないんです もっと強くて
もっとしっかりと 人類のリーダーだから
もうしっかりと生きてるんですね
ですから 優しいだけのというわけじゃないんです
本当に慈しみはお釈迦様にありましたけど
だからといって人にけなしたい放題けなされたりとかね
叱りたい放題叱られたりとかね
それはできません その時はちゃんとそれに合わせてちゃんと対応する
この問題に何が答えかと
そういうふうに答えを探していくんですね
だからその知恵 皆様にも 自動的に発生してくれるように
私はずっと話してきたんです
大体私の話はこの 大体ポイントを掴まないところもあります
で 覚えてこれこそ仏教像やと言ってみんなに言いふらせることもちょっとできないんです
ほとんどもう 15年以上喋ってるんですけど
だからこの仏教というのは
これこれこれこれですよとかね
知ってるんだぞとかね
そういう自慢できないように
もうずっと工夫して話してきましたけど
だからそれは別にどういうことかというと
そのその話をその場で理解して
自分で消化して置いておけば
自分にまた違う智慧というかね
生きる智慧が現れてくるんではないかなと
という話でまあ話してきましたけど
今日はあまり難しいことではないんです
まず論理的なところを言っておきます
それは一番大事なんですね
この世の中で上手にうまく生きるために
どんな論理的には何か
ただいわゆる法則ですね
それは簡単で お釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの中道なんですね
で 中道という言葉がありまして
パーリ語ではマッジマパティパダというんですね
マッジマパティパダということなんです
で マッジマパティパダというのは中道なんですが
2つありますよ 論理的な中道と実践的な中道という 2つあるんです
その 2つを理解しておけば
もう生きる方法はわかるんです
でも中道は決してマニュアルじゃないんです
そこはもうちょっと 日本の方々は戸惑うところなんですけど
なんかマニュアルないんでしょうかと
そうするとそれを開けながら
もうそれ通りにやろうとするんですね
そのマニュアル を作る文化っていうのはもう良くないんです
何でもまあマニュアルがあるんだと
それ見てやればいいんだと
というこの甘さというかね
怠けというかね それはすごい危険なんです
だからこれは中道っていうのはマニュアルではなくて
一応論理的な この基本的なところでどう応用するかっていうことが
その各人が考えなくてはいけないんですね
ですから 中道を私が説明しても
これはマニュアルとして見て
まあ友達と喧嘩するときはどうしますか？と
奥さんと喧嘩する場合はとかね
そんな一つ一つ書いてないんですけどね
だから喧嘩にしたっても
相手によって喧嘩の質が変わりますからね
子供と喧嘩する 友達と喧嘩する
見知らぬ人と喧嘩になる
夫婦の間で喧嘩になる
喧嘩にしても その場でその場で解決方法違いますから
ですから それは自分が一人でやらなくちゃいけないんですね
じゃあ論理的にはどういうことかっていうところだけこちらで説明します
それで論理的な中道がありまして
実践的な中道があるんですね
まず中道という言葉はなぜ出てきたんでしょうかと
で それを見てから この論理的なところと実践的なところを説明します
人間というのはすべての人間ね
偏見的なんですよ それも偏見だよと言えばそれでおしまいですけど
偏見的なんです で それはもう
普通に 別に特別なことではなくて
それが普通なんです 偏見であること
ですから 考え方も偏見であって
生き方も偏見的なんですね
偏っているんです これどうにもならないことで
なぜ偏見的な思考と偏見的な生き方をしていますかというと
まあその人にとってはそれは楽というか
楽なんですよ それで世の中にあるどんな教えでも調べてみてください
ある尺度があって ある何か見方がありまして
その目で見て考えたりするんですね
まあ私たちは宗教の話をしているんだから
まあ例えば西洋的な この絶対的な神という概念の宗教がいくつかあるんですね
それで最初に神は絶対なりという絶対ですよと
そこはまずもう張っておくんですよ
それ張っておいて その下でいろんな哲学
思考 生き方を作っていくんですよ
もうだからもう偏見もいいところなんですね
そこであの まあ例えば私もいろいろ専門の先生方に聞いたことがありますけど
まあ聖書のいろいろな話を聞いて
これはこうあるんだけど
これはちょっとわからない
これはちょっとおかしいではないかとか
いえ それは神様を信じれば
それはもうその通りでわかりますよと
だから神様を信じたら
別に疑問する必要もないし
議論する必要もないし
ああ そうですか はい そうです
それで終わっちゃいますから
例えば世紀末論とか何とかありますけどね
七つのなんとか出てくるとかね
まあそれは 神様を信じていれば
それはその通りということになってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから そういうまあ
聖書だけではなくて その絶対的な神ということを考えている世界では
まあどんな聖典にしたっても
そういうある その角度でしか何一つも説明していないんですね
ですから 正真正銘の偏見論なんですよ
まあ それは宗教の場合は
じゃあ哲学の場合どうですかね
同じことなんです いろいろ哲学者が何かを、論を作っちゃうんですね
それでその論という その中で全部説明しようとする
まあエンピリシズムという哲学がありましてね
まあ経験主義でしたっけね
英語で でプラグマティズムというアメリカで流行ったプラグマティズムって何でしたっけ？
実質主義 まあ そういう哲学があります
で ポジティビズムというね
イギリスで発展した
このロジカルポジティビズムというのですが
哲学思想がありまして
それはどんな言葉でも 言葉一つ入れたら
本当は一応もう偏見になっているんですね
ですから このポジティビズムという思想を作った人々は
そのポジティヴィスティックの立場から全部説明していくんですね
プラグマティズムという実質主義的な思考が正しいと思っちゃえば
何でもその目で見て見て見ていくんですね
まあ そういうことだから
哲学もそういうことで
科学も同じことなんですよ
で 自分で何かを決めて
それでずっと研究していくんですね
まあ医学にしたっても
例えば薬とかね いろんな治療方法とか解決する開発するときでも
まず決まりがありますね
その決まりの中で何か作れるかと
だからエイズ ウイルスに対しては今も抗体はアンチセラムというのは作られてないんですね
だから今までウイルスに対してはこういうことだよとわかっていたんだけど
その同じ方法でずっと研究はしているんですね
でも残念ながらなかなか治療方法が出てこないと
だからそれまあある程度でほとんど無理なんですね
この方法では全くできないということをわかっているんですよ
今はもうやってもやっても
なぜならば そのウイルスが自分の DNA プログラム変えちゃうんだから
自分勝手に だから今敵と思って何か抗体を作っても
次のウイルスはまた違う形をとっているんだから
どうにもならないんですね
ですから この なかなか見つからないということになっていますね
まあ それはもう科学的な世界だから
別にどうにもならないんですけど
基本的にはある決まりがありまして
その決まりの中で治療方法を探しましょうということだから
まあ 仏教から見ればそれも一つの偏見なんです
いわゆる仏教から見れば
偏見にならないものっていうのはないんです
例えば まあ 宗教の世界は絶対的な精神
魂のことをしゃべってますね
それで唯物論を語る人々は
そんな精神なんかはもうという感じで全く認めない
物質のみだと マテリアリズムだからね
唯物ですよと あれなんですかね
あれも偏見でしょ 心やら感情やら霊魂やら魂やら
そういうふうに言うものは全部副産物ですよと
物質の 物質が固まったら
そういうものを副産物として現れるものだけであって
別に唯一な存在として死んでからあの世に行く魂なんかないんだと
だから宗教家がただ人を騙しているだけですよと言って
唯物論者は激しく宗教を批判する
ですから 霊魂論を喋る宗教家は偏見であって
唯物論を語る唯物論者も正真正銘の偏見者なんですよ
世の中で偏見でないという考え方はないんです
だから不思議なことを私は仏教はそうじゃないんだからと言ってるのは言わなくたってもそういうことなんですけど
偏見を否定しているんだから
それでもこうやって言葉にして喋ると
じりじりと偏見に陥っていくんですよ
もうどうにもならない状態なんです
例えばどうにもならないと言って
それも一つの偏見なんですよ
なぜならば ちょっと角度を変えればどうにかなるんだからね
どうにもならないと言えないんですよ
だからまあ ただ我々言葉で考えているんだから
言葉で何か言ったら 言った途端
それはもう固定した
正真正銘の偏見になってしまっちゃうんですね
だからそれは大変なことなんですよ
かなりややこしいんですよ
ですから まずこの論理的には人類はもう人類だけじゃなくて
これはもう心の問題だから
偏見になるんだよということは覚えてほしいんですよ
それで私たちは善か悪か
白いか黒いかというふうに 2つに分けて論理的に分けるんですよ
プラスかマイナスかと
そう分けるんだからこそ
世界にしたっても プラスとマイナスの論に出ているんですよ
陰と何とかっていうね
陰と陽ですか 陰と陽という
まあだからそれ頭で考えるものだからね
結局は まあそうやってこの 2つの極端
人間の考え方にもあります
だから結果としてどうなるんですかというと
何か我々は言うと半分しか真理がないんですよ
そちらには 完全たる真理にはならないんです
どう踏ん張っても まあ半分だったら
それはもうすごい立派なところで
もうほとんど半分の真理にもなりませんね
例えば あの人があんまり良くないんだよと悪い人だよと言ったら
これ真実ですかね 真実じゃないんだけど
まあ全く嘘ということもちょっと言いにくい
なぜならば そう言う人が何かを観察して言っていることだからね
だからもしかすると その人は観察した部分がその通りかもしれません
でも 彼が言うのは あの人があまり良い人間ではありませんということだから
人全体のことを喋っているんでしょうに
だからほんのわずかな真実性しかないんですね
例えば田中さんが悪い人間ですよと
あのほか誰かさんが まあ二郎さんが言うとしますね
じゃあ二郎さんが田中さんという人が生まれた時から今も今生きている瞬間まで
彼の全ての生き方 性格を全てまとめて把握して評価したんでしょうかと
ではないし 彼に出会った時のデータだけで悪い人間だよと判断したんですね
それでその考え方は欠けています
それだけじゃないんですよ
悪いと決めたのは田中さん
もう二郎さんの評価だから
二郎さんがもうこれだったら悪い
これだったらいいというその人の思考だから
それまたそれは絶対的な真理ということでもないでしょうに
ですから さらに真実性低くなっちゃうんですよ
だから田中さんが悪いですと言ったら
田中さんの人生のもしかすると1億分の１しか見てない
それで1億分の１が正しいかと
そうでもない それはこの人の主観も正しくないんだから
これまたもうものすごい少ないんですよ
真実 TRUTHというところは
リライアビリティーというところは
それだけわかってもらえばもう問題ないんですよ
世の中できることは そんな人の話に振り回されたりとかね
落ち込んだりとか 喧嘩したりとか
もうただみんなカラスがキャーキャーと鳴くような感じで
もう泣いてるだけですよ
事実を語っているわけじゃないんです
そういうふうに客観的に計算してみると
１億分の１なんですけど
田中さんが悪いですよということは
でも二郎さんの判断はどうでしょうか
二郎さんも物事をすべて理解しているわけじゃないし
ほんのあっちこっちから入れた情報で善悪判断しているんだから
そちらの真実性もまた１億分の１ぐらいなんですよ
だから１億分の１割る また１億分の１　割るかかけるかわかりませんけど
数字わかりません１億かける１億は　それぐらいなんですよ
真実は 人間の言葉にある真実は
で まあ宗教の話だから
例えば世の中の人口の過半数は　というか
4分の3ぐらい　もっとかな
神様信じてるんですよ
絶対的な神様がいると
でもこの人口の 3分の1
4分の3なんですけど
いまだに神様がいるということは証明できないんですよ
それほどの脳細胞だから
ちょっと頑張ってみたらどうですかね
できないんです それでその方々はそれでもこういうわけでいるんだ
こういうわけでいるんだという
いっぱい知識出してます
でもそれは読めば読むほど
それよりやっぱり 70%同じ論理を否定する論理もあるんですね
だからどうにもならないんですよ
この間 インターネットで何か見ると
こういうことあったんです
あの すごい親切なホームページでしたけど
カトリック教のホームページなんですけど
仏教は大変 キリストカトリック教に対して大変失礼なことを言ってるんだと
で 決して批判的に書いたわけじゃなくて
すごいもう感じも良かったし
だからこの仏教に対する批判だから
カトリック教の あの 何て言いますか
反論ではなくて ディフェンスですね
まあ 自分の立場を証明することだから
じゃあ読んでみましょうということで読んでみようとしたところで笑ってしまっちゃったんですね
まず あの まあ紳士らしく書いていると
それはもう本当に評価しなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ ガキみたいに相手をけなしてやる
そういう気持ちではなくて
すごい丁寧には書いているんですけど
この論理の薄いことに
で  2つに分けて ブッダは人間でした
イエス様は神でした ブッダが亡くなったら火葬して骨になった
イエス様が復活して生き返る
復活しました ブッダが奇跡を否定しました
イエス様が 300 何とか数を書いて
これは奇跡が起こりましたと
そうやってリストを書いていて
もうそれだけで笑っちゃうんです
何をおっしゃってるんでしょうかと
仏教はそれがダメと言ってるんだからね
やっぱりそれで私は考えたのは
そのそちらの方々は自分の信仰にいろいろなことを言われるのは気持ち悪いんです
それは当たり前ですよ
人の信仰にね 誰かが批判するの
それは大変気持ち悪いことは確かなんですけど
だから自分にはちょっと気持ち悪い失礼だということは丁寧には言ってるんだけど
やっぱり言わなかった方が良かったんじゃないかなと
逆に私は思っちゃったんですね
だから しっかりしたジリジリした論理あったならば
私の勉強にもなるし もう本当に仏教はこれだったら負けるぞとなったら
私にもそのホームページに対して何か答えを出してあげることもできたし
なんかすごい残念に思ってしまっちゃったね
それを読んで だから その場合でも考えてほしいのは
こういうことなんですね
世の中では まあ この真理語れないんですよ
何か言っちゃうと それはもう 1億分の1と
また何兆分の 1ぐらいのところしか見てないんですね
どうすればいいんですかね
そういうことで 我々の考え方っていうのは
大体まあそうやって偏見であると
それ理解しただけで 私たちは自分が正しいとね
他人と戦ったりはしません
まあ それはまあ これは私の偏見で
それはあなたの偏見でしょうと
だからまあ偏見だから
もうかすかな何か真実性はあるかもしれませんよということだけでも
落ち着いて我々は生きていられます
ですから この世の中で人類が現れた時から今まで問題なかった瞬間はないんです
社会の中で何を考えて行動しても
どこかで問題が起こる
これはどうにもならないことなんです
で またあまり宗教のことを言っちゃうと
話の内容も良くないんですけど
あの 人類は愛するべきですよと宗教の世界で言うんですよ
理由として何か偏見を出しちゃうんですね
もう神とかなんとか概念を出しちゃうんですね
それで愛するべきですよと言う人々が
なんか人殺しに行ってるんですね
殺してるんです 今も宗教の目的項目で殺してる
インドネシアでも１４０人ぐらい殺されちゃったでしょうに
パキスタンやらね もう
まあ殺すは殺すは殺すは
どうやって聖典で殺してもいいということはありますかね
イスラム教であるんでしょうかね
キリスト教の聖典であるんでしょうかね
殺せ殺せと まあ大体はないんですけど
でもなんかあっという間に知らないうちに
もうものすごく怒りの塊になって
あのもう聖戦という言葉までできていますよ
あの日本訳　聖戦ですね
ジハードという どうやって成り立つんですかね
それが それはこの思考は初めからもう偏見であることに気づいてない
だからそうなるんです
まあ今あの世界で一番問題になっている
この宗教的な争いと戦い
人殺し いじめということはもう激しくありまして
で やっぱり本当にそういう人々は神様を信じているんでしょうかと
と疑うんですよね でも私こそ神様のためにもう徹底的に戦うんだとまた言う
本当に信じているんですかと私が聞きたいんですね
もし信じているならば
この敵を神様が作ったんですよ
だから神様に任せておけばいいのに
ああ 私は手を出すところじゃないんだと
これは神様の作品だと
だからもう怖いと たとえ敵であろうとも
何であろうとも 他宗教の人であろうとも
神様の意識以外で現れたものは何もないんだから
だから放っておけばいいのに
放っておけないところなんでしょうかね
だからそちらに矛盾が生まれてくるんですね
放っておくと何もすることがなくなっちゃうし
だからお釈迦様はずっとこの他宗教に対して見せたのはこの矛盾なんです
あなたが間違っているんだよという一言葉を言わないんです
これ言えないんだから
その代わりにこの矛盾があるんじゃないのと
この絶対的な神様の話を持ってきた人にお釈迦様は同じことを言ったんですね
そういう話を持ってくると
全て全知全能のあるエージェントから作られると言っちゃうと
神という言葉ではないんです
その場合使わない なぜならば
そこら中にいる天界の世界に仏教は神という言葉を使っているんだから
この創造神という場合はちょっとまた考え方が違うんですね
ですから大体エージェントという言葉を使っちゃうんですね
で イスラ まあいい パーリ語はいいんです
ですから そういうふうに
この全てが万物をね そうやって絶対的な力あるものに作られたと言ったら
この世の中にいる人殺し屋も
強盗する人も 嘘つきも
女性を攻撃する人々も
みんな同じエージェントに作られたことになるんだと
人間の意思で何もしなくても
人間の意思でやることでも向こうに管理されているんだと
だったら人間は何もしなくてもいいことになっちゃうんだと
ぼーっとしていればいいんです
それ自体おかしいんじゃないかと
だって努力しなきゃ何も得られないんだから
ですから 一番お釈迦様が言ったのは
この道徳が消えちゃいますよと
それが良くないんだと
道徳が消えてしまいますよと
ですから このまあ そういうふうに
この矛盾というのを見せた経典たくさんありますけど
今日持ってきていないんですが
もうテーマ飛び出ますからね
で この偏見で考えちゃうと矛盾になる
その例は我々の世界を見ても
例えば教育システムというのはみんな考えて考えて作ってはいるんだけど
どうもうまくいかないんでしょうに
どう考えたっても 何年経っちゃうと
なんかそれまた仇になってくるんですね
で 科学的なものを発展しよう
発展しようといって頑張っているんだけど
発展すればするほど あら
ちょっと違うんじゃないかなと
そんなはずではなかったという結果になるんです
例えば 電気を発明したところで
まあすごいこと これで文化や文明やということになったでしょうに
エジソンさんやらいろんな方々ね
それでも電気文化になってきて
やがて電気足らなくなるんですね
もう電気なければ生きていられなくなっちゃったんですね
我々の自然の生き方からあっという間に脱出しちゃったんです
人工的なエネルギーがないと生きていられないんです
それまたおかしいでしょうに
地球に生まれて 人工的なものでないと生きていられない
なんかこの寄生虫みたいな状態になってしまっちゃったんです
寄生虫というのは 他の生命に依存しなきゃ生きていられないんだから
それで電気足らないんだから
また電気作るでしょ？どうなるんですかね
こんなことで プルトニウム使ったり
ウラニウム使ったりしちゃうと
それでもしょうがないとやり続けちゃうと
地球の土地が足らなくなっちゃうんですよ
だって一箇所でね まあそういう何電力
まあ原子力発電所を作ったら
その場所はもう人類に二度と使えないんですよ
もう二度と それでその日本もたくさん使ってますけど
あの廃棄物どうしますかと
どこに捨てればいいんですかね
捨てるところないんです
地球のどこに捨てたってももう帰ってきます
ですから そんな結果は初めは予測していたんですかね
予測しなかったんです
ウランの力が発見したら
これすごい それだけで終わっちゃった
じゃあバンバン使いましょうと
石油もそうでしょうに
これを見つけたら ああ
これすごいと いっぱいあるぞと
じゃあ掘りましょうと
それで石油文化になってしまって
これからどうするんでしょうかと
ですから そういう科学は私たちに本当に役に立っているのに
なんかなんかちょっと違うんじゃないかなと
というところは必ずあるんです
ですから このそれはこの偏見の結果なんです
矛盾があるんです 矛盾がなく
何一つ成り立たないんです
じゃあ政治世界どうですか？経済世界どうですか？で
会社とかいろんなところとかね
どんどんどんどん成長していくと
一日二日で倒産する羽目になっちゃうんですね
一番大きい組織が先に倒産すると
おかしいでしょ あれほどの商売もう兆単位で商売している組織なんですけど
まあ倒産しましたと だから経済世界もそうでしょうし
政治世界もそうですよ
民のために 民衆のために
民衆の気持ちに従って政治やろうと思っちゃうと
結局その民を殺されて終わっちゃうんです
腐敗政治断固反対 反対と言って政治家になったら
その人は捕まっちゃうんですよ
何か汚職したんだからと
ですから この世の中でいつでもそういうことを
この偏見世界だからね
あり得ないんです それでお釈迦様がこの中道というものを教えて
それでうまく生きてみなさいよと
偏見変えることはできないんです
できるのはうまく自分が世渡りすることなんです
で ある サンユッタニカーヤの一番最初に出てくる経典なんですが
小さい経典ですけど お釈迦様にこう聞くんですね
あなたはこの激流はどのように渡りますかと
言ったら 逆らうこともなく
怠ることもなく渡りますよと
で 逆らったら疲れて死んでしまっちゃうんだと
怠ったら沈んで死んでしまいます
結果は同じなんです だから激流はその二つを避けて渡るんだと
それすごい素晴らしい例えですよ
で 激しい激流の中で我々はもがいていろいろ泳ごうとしたっても
疲れてもう溺れて死んじゃうんですよ
じゃあ何もしないでいたら
まあ溺れて死んじゃうんです
激流だから 石にぶつかったり
ぶつかったり あるいは渦巻きにはめられたりしちゃうと
それで終わり 何も努力しないんだから
でも何か方法はあるんですよ
それを渡るために だからそれは激流は一番いい例えなんですよ
この激流に陥った人 落ちた人がその水の流れを計算しながら
この場合はもう一緒にちょっと行った方があっちは渦巻きあるんだから
ちょっと避けた方がいいとかね
ここら辺の水は一応安定しているんだから
じゃあ泳ぎましょうとかね
そうやって流れと一緒に
合わせて合わせて岸まで行くんです
岸に行ったらじゃあバイバイと
その技なんですね 仏教の生き方というのはすべて
ですから 論理的なこの中道とは
今説明した論理的な中道なんですけど
ですから 世の中のどんなものでも偏見だと
一応もう偏見的にでもいいんですからね
決めておけば楽なんです
だからこれを偏見と言ったっても
まあ捨てるっていう意味でもないんです
捨てましょうと そういう意味でもなくて
やっぱり人間には偏見しかできない
音楽家は音楽しか もう他のことをやっちゃうと生きていられないんだからね
その人は音楽にもう全部人生かけちゃうし
で エンジニアはその世界に人生をかけちゃうしね
だから当然偏見になるし
でも一部が役に立つ
音楽家はもう朝から晩まで
その音の世界だけ考えて考えて生活するかもしれませんけど
まあいくらか我々にももしかするときれいな音を作ってくれるかもしれません
まあ 作る分は役に立つ
そうやっていろいろ人が何か何かをして生きているんであって
誰もこれこそ人生っていうことは言えないと思います
我々にしたっても 我々も何かをして生きているんだけど
これこそ人生 完璧な完全たる人生っていうことはないんです
まあ 何か一部選んで頑張っているだけで
だから生き続けたければ
自分が選んだ一部はどれぐらい人の役に立っているかと
という分で 自分の能力
偏見的な能力を買われちゃうんですよ
あまりにも偏見になっちゃうと
もう生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
あなたみたいな人にはこういう品物を売りませんよと言っちゃうと
もうダメなんですよ あまりにも偏見主義になっちゃうんで
その場合は 例えば芸術家がいるとしましょう
芸術は自分の主観で自分で最高
傑作というんですかね
ね 傑作という何かを作ったりしますね
誰かがなんだこれ変だなと言っても
まあとにかく自分の家に置物必要ですから
これ買ってくれと 売ってくれと言ったら
あんたこれ評価もできないんだから売れませんよと言っても
それちょっとどうかなと思いますね
それで評価する人がいるかもしれませんけど
子供がああ これ面白そうと　でも買えません
だからね　まあそういう世界ですから
まあ決して私たちのわがままで生きていられるわけじゃないんですね
だから 私たちのわがままな生き方でも
いくらかいくらかでも
人に何かコネクションを取っているところで生き続けているんですね
そこら辺計算して計算して生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
じゃあそれから中道的な
実践的な中道って何なのかというと
これ実際に我々は喋ったりしますね
言葉には徹底的に気をつける
こんなまあ感情的で言いたいんだから言いましたよとかね
言われるんだから言いましたよ
言いましたよとかね それは危険
言葉っていうのは本当はものすごい毒だと思った方がいいんです
これでもう大変なことになります
ですから 喋る前にも内容を考えて観察して
喋る時でも観察して 喋ってからも
あれ言ってよかったんでしょうかと
そういう 3段階で判断しないとわからないんですよ
言う前に ああ これは言った方がいいと自分の主観的に判断はしますよ
いきなりでちょっと待って
一旦停止して言ったらどうなるでしょうかと
どんな結果になるでしょうかと考える
ああ そんな悪い結果にならない
良い結果になるみたいだなと思ったら
まあ喋りますけど 喋る時もチェックするんですよ
これでいいかな これでいいかなと
その時見つけたらやっぱりまずい
すぐやめられますからね
この悪いこと 喋る以前に発見したら喋れないことになるでしょ
だから害はない 喋る途中で発見したら
その場でやめてやめればもう害は少なくなる
喋った分だけ以外で喋らなかった分ではもう安全なんですね
喋ってからでまた計算しなくちゃいけない
良かったかと もし悪かったならば
やっぱりまあああいうことは二度としないというふうに決めなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 喋ってからも考え計算しないと
また同じ失敗を二度も繰り返しちゃうんですね
まあ 終わったことだからしょうがないよと
思うのもよくないんですよ
やっぱり失敗しましたと
ですから 特にこの共同体の生き方って
一番大事なことは この言葉
それはものすごい気をつけた方がいいんです
それから この丁寧にしゃべろうと
例えば日本語みたいなね
言語になると とにかく丁寧に丁寧にしゃべろうとする
みんな忘れてる あれ 誰に対する礼でしょうかと
相手に対する礼をしている
結局相手を侮辱しているんですけど
丁寧な言葉で だからこの
そういうことでちょっと曖昧になるんですね
言葉が 特に日本語の特色なんですけど
あの  60%しか喋れません
残る 40%は相手がまあ一応わかっていると
それを日本の文化だと
まあ言ったりはします
その相手の理解に任せていいんですかね
例えば もうあのね あの
ほら この間ね あの人 そうですねと
向こうもあいさつするでしょうね
本当に同じ人のことでしょうかね
だから私とみんな会話する
あまり会話できないのはそういうわけ
まあ この間はすみません　 そう言いますけど
全然反省しません 怒るんです
その場合は この間って何なのかと
意味がないんだから はっきり言いなさいと
でなくて 私はこの間とどの間考えればいいんですかね
それに私は妄想しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこで 例えば ある人が私に失礼なことをしたとする
それは失敗 人間の中にありますからね
それ 一回何か失礼なことをしたとしても
もしかするともう 100回ぐらい私に対してすごい親切な行為もした可能性もありますね
それでその人はその一回の失敗のことを思い出して
この間すみませんでしたと言ったら
私が思い浮かんだのは
その人が前にした もしかするといいことだったらどうしますかね
あ この人 この間私を助けてくれて
今は謝ってるんだと 今後悔してるんだと思っちゃうでしょうね
だって覚えてるのは その人に助けてもらった例がいっぱいありまして
見た途端 ああ まあよく知ってる
よく助けてくれる人だなという感じがあるのに
この間すいません　でこの人は私に親切にしてくれたことを後悔してるんではないかなと
そういう誤解になるんですよ
ですから この間ではなくて
もうそれははっきりした方がいいんですよ
それはもう失礼なことじゃないんです
だから 言葉に気をつけるだけではなくて
この曖昧で喋ってはいけません
自分が伝えたい意味をきちんとして
それは相手が反対しようが賛成しようが
それは別な話で こういうことが
まあ A プラス B イコール C だったらそこまで言わないと
AプラスＢですねと言ったっても
あの人は C にするか  X にするか
Z にするか分からないでしょうに
だから私は A プラス B イコール C と言いたいんだよと
相手がいえ 違います
Aプラス B は C ではなくて D ですよと言うかもしれません
それは別の話で だからこの言葉に気をつけるだけではなくて
言葉は明確に主語と動詞が合って喋ってほしいと
時々主語がどちらかぐにゃぐにゃで
動詞が ほとんど日本の場合は動詞がね
かなりぬるぬるしていますからね
そういうことでかなりこのトラブルが起きるんですよ
誤解されて 誤解されて
誤解されて だから本来心が優しい人だったら問題ないんだけど
本来ものすごく批判的な性格だったらね
人の欠点しか見えない人間見るでしょうに
人の欠点しか見えない
どこに行ったって悪いことしか見えない
そういう特別な眼鏡をかけてるんです
そういう人々と喋り合っちゃうと
ものすごく誤解しちゃうんですよ
だから私の時代 私は何でも論理で処理しようとするんですね
厳密な論理で そうすると
人を言うことをそんな風に処理しちゃうと
もうものすごくバカバカらしく見えちゃって
何言うんです あんた言ってること自分で否定してるんではないかとか
そういうことになっちゃうんですよ
あまり言わないんだけど
ですから 相手に言うことがその責任持って
相手にも伝わるという
一番人間が言葉に　一番大事に言葉に気をつけた方がいいんですね
ですから なぜ仏教でこの無駄話やめるということを言っていますかというと
無駄話っていうのは このしゃべる快感ですよ
いわゆるお話を楽しむという
内容を楽しむということじゃないんです
だからこの単なるしゃべる快感でしゃべると
この言葉に気をつけるということはできなくなっちゃうんですね
時間無駄になる まあただ無駄話だよと言いながら喋ってますけど
相手が全部無駄話にとるんですかね
人間というのは偏見主義者ですから
自分の偏見でこの言葉は本音のことで取るんだよと
これはもう認めないんだけど
随分自分で判断して取ってるんだから
そういう危険なんですよ
まあそういうことで この
まあ自分が安心して生きているためには
この言葉は明確にしゃべる
事実のみを語る それからこのできるだけ言葉を少なくすることですね
で まあそれからこのもう一つ
ものすごい大事なことがあるんです
聞く人のプライドを全く傷つかないように喋らなくちゃいけない
たとえ相手のことを批判するにしても
批判っていうのは健康的な社会でもあってほしいことでしょうし
批判しても その人の人格
人のプライドを傷つけてはいけないんですね
プライドを傷つけちゃうと
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
で そういうまあまあね
実践的な中道っていうのは
皆様ご存知のこの八正道なんですね
だから今日は八正道を説明する時間はないし
ですから言葉だけそこら辺を覚えておけばよろしい
それからこの常に落ち着いていること
まあ情ということですね
で いわゆる感情的に舞い上がって混乱状態では生きてはいけません
感情的になったら 舞い上がってきたら
混乱したら すぐもう自分の部屋にでも行ってじーっとした方がいいんです
誰ともしゃべらないで
すぐそこでコミュニケーションをカットして
なかなかすごく落ち着いて機嫌がいいんだったら
落ち着いているんだったら
その時だけ人と喋ったり行動したりする
ですから 正定っていうのはそういうサマーディってそういうことなんですね
正念という言葉もありますね
正念というのはいつでも状況を見ている
どういう状況か どういう状況かと
で まあかなり難しい生き方かもしれませんけどね
まあだから僕は怠けは嫌なんですよ
怠けたらもう危険だと
やっぱりいつでも どんな場にいても
その状況を見ながら 状況を見ながらいる
そういうふうな生き方ですね
それから頭をしっかりする
思考 正思ですね 正見
正思という 2つ初めに出てくるんです
そういうところで この実践的な中道があるんです
それで 世の中でうまくいくためには
我々は中道的な生き方をするんだと
中道的な生き方というのをまとめてみます
簡単です 判断して生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
これがすごい危険なんですよ
判断すること 判断した途端
もう偏見になっているんだから
でも 生きているうえでは判断しなくちゃいけない
東に行くか 西に行くかと決めないとどうにもならないんですよ
判断は良くないんだけど
人の生き方っていうのはすべて判断の連結ですよ
判断が間違えるんだったら
人の人生は全部完璧に間違っているんです
だって判断して 判断して判断して間違っちゃうでしょうね
次の判断して それまた間違っちゃうでしょうね
中道っていうのは 本当は判断の仕方なんです
だから完璧な判断はできないかもしれませんけど
この状況をちゃんと把握する
状況を把握して 一応ベターな結論を作る
あ この場合はこれしか良い選択ないんだよと
で 次のポイントは これ中道だから
その判断こそ絶対的で正しいととらないこと
次の瞬間で状況が変わるんだから
その判断ではいけないんですよ
ですから 判断して判断にとらわれない
その生き方なんです
それでよく人間間違うのは見たことがありますよ
最初は何か良いことを判断して
いいことをしましょうと
それからもう生きてはいるんだけど
どんどん私の人生 私の命はこれやというふうにもう定着してしまっちゃって
それから道が外れてしまっちゃうんです
で 例で言えば このもう何人かいろいろ人に出会ったことありますけど
このもうやっぱり肉魚食べたら良くない
失礼だ これ残酷だといきなり決める
まあ残酷だといえば残酷かもしれませんだけど
じゃあ菜食主義になるんだと言って
それは徹底する 徹底した途端
よく見てみたんです そういう人々が
肉魚食べる人よりも残酷なんです
なんでそうなるんですかと
優しさがない 激しい もう人をけなす
肉魚食べる人に対してものすごい堂々と悪口を言う
もう軽視する 区別する
差別する 私の家に来るなよとか
あんた方は とかね えらいことなんですよ
ある人に聞いたんです
あんたは動物に対して親切ですけど
なんで徹底的に人間を嫌ってるんですかと
というエンミティ 人類に対してなんでそんなにもエンミティ怒り持ってますかと
それは人間が悪いんだから
動物にだったら親切ですよと
だから逆に私の反応が出たのは
あなた人間ですか？と聞きたかったんですけど
人間だから結局 でも最初はその人の話を聞いてみたら
やっぱり優しい気持ちであまりにも動物を殺されて殺されて
もうバクバクと食べていて
これはちょっと良くないんではないかなということで始めたことが
やがて恐ろしい人間になってしまっちゃったんですよ
だから悲しくてかわいそうなんですよ
友達と付き合いができなくなっちゃうし
喋ったら喧嘩になるし
よくしょっちゅうその人は喧嘩したんだから
誰とも そういうことで
時々我々は良いとする判断するんだけど
残念なことにその判断に囚われちゃうんですよ
そうするとまた極端な偏見になってしまって
また不幸になるんですね
だから判断というのは一時的条件付き
この部屋に暖房をつけてはいますけど
だからこの部屋に来るたびに暖房をつける必要はないでしょうに
それは条件付きでしょうに
だから実際の世界 そういうことだから
例えば電気があるんだから全部入れましょうという
なんであるんだから入れるためにあるんだと
それはちょっと違うでしょうに
この部屋で電気はもう 100個ぐらいあるかもしれませんだけど
だからって 100個も入れる必要ありますかね
それ全て条件付きなんですよ
ですから 例えばこの部屋で二人だけ仕事をしている場合は
1個の電気で十分でしょうに
みんないっぱい入ってきたら
まあそれなりに適量な電気量でよろしいでしょうし
ですから この判断というのはいつでも流動的で動いていなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは哲学になると 生きる哲学になると
かなり楽に生きていられます
まあ 例えば人がね 悪いことをしたりすると
いきなりあの人悪いと判断する
でもその判断するタイミングはいいんだけど
その悪いって それ判断はやっぱり流動的なんで動くんですよ
条件変わったら違う判断しなくちゃいけないんです
一生同じ 判子でいくわけじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
人間というのはその場でその場で変わる
我々の態度も生き方も
その場でその場で変わる
ですから その変わって変わっている条件の中で
一番ベターのあるいはベストの選択で生きていればいいんです
この場合はベストは何でしょうかと
このその場合のベストは絶対的なベストというわけじゃなくて
状況が変われば関係なくなっちゃうんです
そういう生き方なんですね
それからこの人間のちょっとした失敗ありまして
なかなかうまくいく場合は判断できて
良い判断できましたと
良い決断できましたと
それは 2回    3回  4回
5回とかね あるいは大きなことに大きな判断してうまくいった時とかね
なんか自信ついちゃうんですよ
自信ついてしまっちゃうと
もう次から判断できなくなっちゃうんです
自分が判断したら これ以上うまくいくぞという自信がついちゃうと
ですから 我々の判断能力もいつでもうまくいくわけじゃない
鈍くなる場合もあります
それで仏教は推薦するのは
賢者の意見を聞きなさいと
インテリの意見を聞きなさいと
仏教は民主主義なんですけど
意見を聞いたりする時と実行したりする時は
民衆の意見を聞きません
みんなの意見を聞きません
その時はインテリの意見を聞く
自分でもわからない 例えば
100人で何か行動しなくちゃいけないんですよ
100人にも聞きません 自分でもどうすればいいかわからない
それで100人の間で知識能力ある判断能力あるインテリの人々に意見を聞く
聞いてこういう風にやりましょうと
だからこの民主主義だといっても
完璧に全て正しいわけじゃないんですよ
だから民主主義の国家の場合は
どんな判決であろうか
国民の意見でなければいけませんでしょうに
じゃあ一般国民知ってますかね？核問題についてどうすればいいんでしょうかと
国際問題についてどうしますかと
あるいは何か他の問題についてどうしますかとかね
わからないでしょうに
だからみんなの意見聞いちゃうと
もうとんでもない落とし穴に落ちる可能性もあります
ですから 賢者のインテリの意見を聞きなさいと
そこら辺ははっきりするんですよ
自分一人で何かできない場合は
頭のいい人に 信頼できる人にアドバイスを受ける
目上の人にアドバイスを受ける
そういうふうな生き方になります
じゃあ　それから早く話しますけど
まあそれから一応論理的なところはそこら辺で終わり
それからこの偏見世界について
またなんでそうなるかっていう
個人という 立場から考えてみます
で なんで我々は偏見的な人間になってますかというと
これは構成上の問題で
我々はこの主観的な人間になってるんですね
自分の目で見て 自分が見た世界を作って
自分が聞いて 自分が聞いた世界を作る
だから私は知ってるのは私が見た世界
私が聞いた世界なんですね
そこで不思議なことに
同じものを見ても 二人が二つの意見を持っちゃうんですね
二つの感情を持っちゃうんですね
だからどんな人でも 自分だけの見た世界
聞いた世界持ってるんですね
この個性なんです ポイントは
個性イコール主観世界なんですね
ですから普遍性がないんです
それで確かめる方法もない
だから何かを見る  100人見たら
100人は 100種類の意見を出しちゃうんですよ
ものを見て みんな同じ意見でわーっとなることはないんです
いくらみんな一斉に声を出しても
それでも一人一人 の気持ちが違うんです
ですから 誰が何をしゃべっても
それがいつでもその人の意見なんですよ
それが正しいか悪いかも間違っているかもわからないし
それに乗せられていいかどうかもわからないし
大体まあそうやって我々は人の意見を聞いては生きてますけど
それでいろいろトラブルを起こしたりするんですね
人に言われて このご飯美味しいですよと言って
私たちは食べるでしょうに
そのことで食べてみたら
自分で言うと美味しくなかったっていうこと
どんなものについてたって
そうやって我々は人が言ったんだからやるということはありますけどね
まあそういうことで やっぱり一般的な秩序はすべてこの偏見ということになってしまっちゃうんですね
で それから人間というのはすごいこの自己愛ということがあるんですよ
いわゆる自分しか愛せないんですよ
自分しか可愛くないんです
何も だからまあ人言うことやらね
世の中言ってることっていうのはね
まあそれほど人類を愛して言ってるわけじゃないんです
そういうことだから 世の中生き息苦しいんですよ
で あの まあたまたま大きい心で物事を考える人はね
まあまあいることは全くないってことはないんですけど
やっぱり大勢の人々がやっぱり自分のことしか考えてないんです
会社作る人が自分が豊かになることを考えてあって
最初から会社を設立する前も
やっぱり 10人の人々をなんとかして雇わなくちゃいけないと全然考えてないんです
いや 私は会社作って とにかく私の目的は 100人を雇うことだよと
100人に気持ちよく給料をいただいてもらって
ご飯食べて楽しく生きているために頑張らなくちゃあかんぞと思う人がいますか？いません
会社設立しようと思っちゃったら
それは自分が利益を得るためなんですよ
そのために人を雇うんであって
人のために人を雇うために会社を作るわけじゃないんです
それははっきりしているんです
ですから 会社の社長を信頼して
信仰して 徹底的にそういう通りにやったんだからといって
雇われた側が幸せになるということは大体ありえないんです
成り立たないんです 学校の先生の言うことを真面目に聞いたんだからといって
子供は幸せになることはないんです
なぜならば 学校の先生だって自分のことが一番可愛いんですよ
だから子供は言うことを聞いてくれると自分が楽なんです
だから言うことを聞きなさいよと言うんです
それで言うことを真面目に聞く子供たちが
どこかで馬鹿を見て終わっちゃうというか
まあそれはもう具体的な世の中であることでしょうに
じゃあお母さんの言うことを真面目に聞いてみたらどうなるんですかね
お母さんという存在っていうのは
もうかなり子供のことを考えるんですよ
かなり考えるんです まあ世の中で自分のことを心配して考えるといえば
お母さんとお父さんぐらいのもん
二人だけぐらいのもんですけど
兄弟なんかは全然考えません
兄弟のことなんか まあ両親というのはやっぱり子供のことは考えますけどね
でもそれも 100%じゃないんですよ
だからお母さん言う通りに全部やっちゃうとうまくいかないんです
やがてもう大変なことになっちゃうんです
不幸になっちゃうんです
すごい危険になっちゃうんですよ
もう何もできなくなっちゃう場合もありますから
お母さんがなければ 精神的な病気になるところまで行っちゃいますからね
そういうことで この自己愛ということが我々の大変仇になっているんだから
それも理解する 理解して
もういわゆる持ちつ持たれつというかね
もうあんまりとらわれないように
まあ淡々と世の中で生きていればいいんです
適切に人の話も聞く お母さんの話も適切に聞く
それだけで行くのではなくて
自分の意見もありますから
それとちょっと合わせてみるとかね
それだけで行くのではなくて
友達の話もちょっと聞いてみるとか
これ 誰一人も自分のこと可愛いとは思ってないんだから
じゃあちゃんと自分の判断もいくらか合わせて生き方を決める
そうしないんだからね
みんなあの人言ったんだからやりますと
それで間違うんですよ
それは世の中を渡る方法じゃないんです
あの人の話を聞きましょうと
それではもう間違っちゃうんです
だから親の話も聞く 先生の話も聞く
友達の話も聞くんだけど
誰一人も 100%自分のことを心配して言ってるわけじゃない
いわゆる自分のことを理解できないんだから
主観世界だから それで意見を見て判断して
自分の意見も入れて判断して
じゃあこういう風にしましょうと
そういう生き方でかなり気楽に生きていられます
正しく　 次になんでこの世の中難しく
嫌な世界になったかというと
この人間の生きる哲学
ポリシーなんですよ 我々は何のために生きているかというと
単なる快感を得るためなんです
快感は何のためかと言ったって誰もわからないんです
もう快感を得るんだったら何でもするんです
爆弾でも落としちゃうんです
ですから 人類の生きる道っていうのは
目の刺激 耳の刺激 体の刺激
舌の刺激 脳の刺激というね
そういうとにかく快感を得るだけの生き方
そういうことだから いろいろ問題が起きたりします
まあ そういう生き方ですから
社会で何を見ても 我々には矛盾
矛盾に見えます 教育の世界では矛盾に見えます
先生が言うことを真面目に聞くと
結果としては矛盾になってしまっちゃう
じゃあ子供が生徒が自分の意見でバリバリと言ってきちゃう
言ってきちゃうと　必ず矛盾に出会います
だから自分の意見で言っても不幸になるし
先生の意見で言っても不幸になる
だからどんな道を行っても最後は不幸ということが決まっているんです
それは思考的な矛盾を持っているだからなんですね
その原因です 今説明したのは
自己愛と主観主義であることと
快感を追っていくんだということで
で 普遍的な問題 もう一つはありますね
我々の感情 すべての生命に普遍的な感情は
仏教でいう貪瞋痴なんですね
だから生きる衝動 生かされているエネルギー
生きていきたいというすごいエネルギーを持ってますね
あれが貪瞋痴です これは別に聖なる何かエネルギーで我々生きているわけじゃないんです
誰でもまあ 単なる貪瞋痴で生きてみましょうと
頑張ってみましょうということで
じゃあ今日も元気で明るくてと
もう貪瞋痴なんですよ
だから引きこもりになる人であろうか
今日は明るく元気で頑張るぞという人も
二人とも貪瞋痴の衝動なんです
だからこの貪瞋痴の衝動で
じゃあ頑張りましょう
じゃあ人類に何かしましょう
じゃあ何か発明しましょうとか頑張っても
どこかでまた矛盾成り立つのです
科学研究する人はできればノーベル賞を欲しいと
これあるのは 誰でもあのメダル欲しいというぐらいの単純な欲なんですよ
なんで科学者たる人がね
こんな子供みたいな子供騙しに
結局やられますよ 精神的に
例えば自分の名前推薦されちゃって
それで落選しちゃうと結構ショックなんですよ
もう子供と大して変わりはないんですよ
科学者たる人でも まあそういう世界ですので
この貪瞋痴が衝動であります
ですから 生き方にはいつでも矛盾というものは出てきます
まあ 医学も見ましょう
医学の場合は単純な思考があるんですよ
それは死にたくはない
元気バリバリでいたい
その 2つも何ですか？元気バリバリでいたいということは
むさぼり 貪瞋痴の貪ということ
死にたくはないということは
怒り 死ぬのは嫌だから
ですから 医学はなぜ発展するかというと
欲と怒りがあるからなんです
それで結果としてはそんなはずではなかったという結果なんです
医学は発展しているんですけど
どう我々は　何の病気もなく元気でいますかというと
そうじゃないでしょうに
だからもう医者もどうにもならない状態なんです
一旦言ったらもう決まってるものは全部やらなくちゃいけない
それは患者さんにいいか悪いか
それはもうやっぱりこの薬やめましょうと思ったら
その医者の首が飛んじゃうね
その場合は そうするともうやらなくちゃいけない
あるいは病院の経営の問題も出てくると
いらん薬までいらん治療までしたりもする
これはもう大事な命でしょうに
持っていったところで何されるかわからないことにまで発展しているんですね
そこで医者も怖いし 裁判かけたらまた怖いし
ですから まあえらく気をつけて
いろいろ調べて調べて
意見聞いて意見聞いてやってると
またもう遅くなっちゃう
手遅れになる時もあるしね
それで医学の場合は この怒りに基づいて
とにかくこの敵を殺すという方法で発展していますね
ですから どんな薬を飲んでも
体には必ず害があるんです
まあ そういうことで たとえ医学にしても
いくら真剣に研究してして結果を出しても
それから予測しなかった意外な結果もそこら辺で表れているんです
だから我々の生き方ってそういう生き方なんですね
そういうことで必要なのは
これ 答えは思考の転換
貪瞋痴で言ったら いつでもこの矛盾の世界
貪瞋痴でどこまで教育システムを改良しても
結果はそんなはずではなかったという結果になるんです
それはもう避けられません
ですから 我々は思考を転換すれば
貪瞋痴の代わりに違うエネルギーを入れてみれば
お釈迦様が言う 不貪不瞋不痴というね
貪りの代わりに まあやっぱりみんな仲良くすればいいかと
ただ 自分が得ることではなくて
自分が与えるものは何かないかと
人類に他人に対して だから生まれてからも あなたは頑張ってください
あなたに何ができるんでしょうか
世の中のために与えることが
それがあなたの生きる道だよと言ったら
その子がどれぐらい儲かるかっていうことは全く考えないでしょうね
何を社会に与えればいいんですか？何を社会に与えればいいんですかと
それで生きてるでしょうに
それで悪くなると思いますか？それでこの人に儲かる技を教えてないんだから
貧乏になるんだと とんでもない話なんですよ
社会に与えて与えて生きている人はもう損得を考える必要もないんです
倒産という考え方も出てこなくなっちゃうんです
とても簡単ですよ 子供が生まれたら
もうあんた立派な人間になれ
いい大学に行けというふうなね
あの精神いじめやめて
あんたに何ができるんでしょうかと
それ見なさいよと 他に対して
世の中に対して あなたに何が貢献できるかと
じゃあ毎日頑張ってみなさいと
だからもう何でも役に立つか立たないかというね
たとえ子供はいろいろガラクタやらね
まあ小さい時はね あのなんていうのは
牛乳パックやらいろんなものをいろんなものを作ったりするでしょ
その時でもやっぱり何か役に立つんでしょうかということをね
子供はなんとか苦労して牛乳パックで鉛筆入れを作ったりする
ああ これはいいわ これは役に立つんだと
１日 ２日 ３日間でも それは鉛筆入れとして使ったりとかね
そうやって役に立つことを教えてあげると
自然破壊して遊ぶぞという今の子供たちの生き方を変えるんですよ
今の子供たちの遊びっていうのは
ものすごい自然破壊でしょ
だから貪瞋痴の代わりに思考を展開する
あのケネディさんが言ったことと同じ言葉なんですよ
国があなたに何をしてくれるかと聞かないで
あなたが国に対して何をしてあげるかということを考えなさいと言ったでしょうに
それ同じ考え方なんですよ
貪りではなくて 私たち個人個人で
私ですよ 私に社会に対して
人類に対してできることは何なのかと
と見て そればっかりやって
思う存分やって生きていると
これより何十倍も力強く生きていられますよ
毎日充実感も出てくる
何も自然破壊にもならないし
明日何食べようかと困る必要もなくなっちゃうんです
だから社会が支えてくれるのは社会を支えてあげる人なんですよ
私が作った品物が人間の役に立つならば買ってくれるでしょうに
役に立たなかったら買ってくれないんですね
だからその貪瞋痴の思考だから
今作っている品物っていうのはほとんどガラクタで役に立たない
買っても 2, 3ヶ月とかになってくると
このボロ見えてくるし
それで新製品また買わなくちゃいけないし
それ買っても 3ヶ月とかでまたダメになる
でまた新製品買わなくちゃいけないし
いつでも欠陥のものを作っては売る
作っては売る なんで欠陥のものを作って売るかと
とにかく早く売りましょうと言って儲かります
それ思考でしょ 基本 私はずっと苦労したんだから
このメモを印刷するためにトラブルばっかり起きちゃって
機械で一つも私が作ったトラブルじゃないんですよ
人為的に自分が作ったトラブルではないのです
そこら辺は気をつけていますから
この作った機械と作られたというか
まあね その機械とそのプログラムのトラブルなんですね
だから欠陥のものを作って売りさばいちゃって
これ使う私たちの時間も無駄になる
そうするとこれダメよと
で また新しいものを買い替えなくちゃいけない
それまた同じでしょうに
だから永久的に苦しむだけに終わっちゃうんです
だから思考さえ変えればすべて終わっちゃうでしょ
問題は だから怒りの代わりに慈しみと無知の代わりに理解能力と
理解能力というのは一番世の中で楽しいことなんですよ
みんな忘れているんです
楽しいっていうのは もうふざけて遊ぶことやと思ったんだけど
それって苦しいんですよ
例えばみんな何時間でも　将棋ですか
そういうものは何時間でもやっているでしょうに
じゃあサッカーだったら早くも疲れます
将棋やる人はもう３時間でもやるんですから
やっぱりその方が面白くて楽しいんですよ
だから知識なんですね
智慧なんですよ 楽しみっていうのは
そういう意識展開ですね
お釈迦様は推薦するのは
そうするとこの矛盾が消えるんだと
すべての矛盾が世の中に
まあＵターンだと言いたいんですけど
今の行く道とは違いますと
Uターンと言ったら またみんな問題を作る可能性ありますからね
じゃあ元に戻るんでしょうかと
だからＵターンということはあまり良くないんです
とにかく意識展開なんですけどね
じゃあちょっと休みますか
続けていますか ちょっと休みを入れましょう
ではよろしいでしょうか
じゃあこれから少々具体的な　と言っても
私は具体的な話は下手ですから
まあ入ってみます
まあ私たちはどうすればいいかということで
あの 大体我々にはこういう考え方がありますね
私の気持ちをわかってくれと
自分を全然理解してくれないと
よく文句おっしゃるでしょうに
で それが危険です それになると
この世の中で生きていられません
なぜかというと 自分の気持ちわかってしまった瞬間で
自分がもう捕まってるんです　他人に
そのわかっていただいた瞬間から
その人の言う通りに その人の希望通りに生きていなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それは誰も気にしないんですよ
これとんでもないことなんです
時々ありますよ 自分の気持ちを読まれたという場合はね
その場合は その人の自由自在
こちらは断れないんですよ
何か言ったら だってこちらの気持ちわかってるんだから
他のこともできなくなるんです
だからみんなこの中道的じゃないんだから
ただ自分こそ偉いというふうに思っていて
思っているんだから 自分の主観的な世界をね
とにかく理解してくれと
それは自分勝手にね 自分で主観で考えることやら
好き嫌いやら感情やらね
そういうものは相手が理解できないこともないんですけど
理解したならば 相手の思うままに生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
本当はこの自分の気持ちを理解してくれっていうことが
自分の首に鎖をかけて飼ってくれっていうことなんです
その気持ちは無い方がいいんです
ですから逆はいいんです
相手の気持ちを理解すると
まあどちらでもその場のその場の判断だから
でも逆は仏教的に使えば悪くないんです
例えば自分の気持ちを理解したら
自分が支配されちゃいますから
相手の気持ちを理解して相手を支配するんでしょうかと
それは良くないことなんですけど
では 人気ある政治家って誰ですか？人が何考えて
何が好きかとどんな言葉好きかとわかってる人でしょうね
そこで人の気持ちに合わせる
アメリカの政治的な宣伝を見ても
一般アメリカ国民の気持ちに合わせる
だから日本の政治家よりも知識的にはすごいレベルが低いんです
言ってることは　ただこうやってパフォーマンスいろいろやったり
奥さん連れてきて 子供連れてきて
みんなの前で抱っこしたり
いろんなことをやったりとかね
そういうやり方やって
これでみんな気持ちいいということで
それで投票しちゃうんですよ
ですから この相手の気持ちわかったら
もう思い存分相手を動かせるということができるんだから
それはもう悪い世界でよく使ってます
時々この悪いことに人を使うことで捕まる場合も
その人の欠点見つかるんですよ
お金に困っているとか
なんとかとかね それであんたすごくお金に困ってるでしょ
じゃあまあ私のところに来たらね
もうあんたなんとか助けてあげるぞと
それでお金欲しいということも読まれちゃったんだから
それからいろんな法律を犯す仕事でもやらせたりする
このブラックメールはなんで成り立つんですかね
ブラックメールですか？脅迫ですかね
日本語になると　脅迫されたりするでしょ
それは自分の何か弱みを握られた時でしょうに
だからやっぱり自分を理解されてしまっちゃうと
もうどうにもならないんですよ
だから軽く生きていかなければ
もう自分の気持ちではなくて
人の気持ちを理解することなんですね
人の気持ちを理解すると
自分にはうまく生きることはできるんです
とにかくもう世渡り術だからしょうがないんです
だから他人に読まれるということでは生きていられないんです
それぐらい自分が弱いということなんです
それぐらいしっかりしていないということなんです
時々我々はこういうふうに
あの人何考えてるか分からないんだという場合あるでしょうね
本当はその人を考えていることを理解したいという気持ちはあるんです
なぜなら 我々も支配したいんですよ
何考えるか分からないという人は管理できないでしょ
だからはっきりした事実なんです
世の中で やっぱり自分の生き方
うまく幸せに生きたければ
できるだけ人々の気持ちを理解するということなんです
ですが 私はこの今日の講義ではなくて
他の講義をした時は激しく言うんですよ
人の気持ちは全くわからないんだと
不可能だと 他人の気持ちを理解することなんかはありえないと
本当は理解したつもりだけですよというふうに堂々と言ったことが、覚えがあるんです
相手の気持ちを理解したということも
結局自分の主観ですよと
ということも言いましたけど
今日はもっと軽い実践論だからね
生きる方法だからね で
まあ主観の世界だったらね
相手の気持ちは理解できるわけじゃないし
まあそれはそうなんですけど
お釈迦様はやっぱりこの実践を教えたんですね
相手の気持ちを理解する方法があるんです
その方法は まず自分の気持ちを理解する
人間というのは 自分が何者かとさっぱりわからないにも関わらず
相手のことを理解しようとするどころじゃなくて
説教までする 世直しまでする
管理しようともする その管理しようとする
その本人が何者かと自分でもわからない
だからそこはあまりうまくいかない　いく世界じゃないんです
ですから まず自分で何なのかと
自分の中身をちゃんと観察する
そうすると まあ最初は正しくできませんけど
どんどん 100%正しく観察できるんですよ
だから私はこのちょっとした瞑想遊びなんかを教える場合は
あの 100%でやってくださいということを言うんですよ
自己観察を確実性100%
例えば痛みがあるといえば
本人に痛みがあるんだから
それは 100%正しいでしょうに
瞑想中で音が入ったら
車の音をカラスの音と言わないで音だと言ってください
と そうすると音ということは 100%正しい
車かカラスかということはちょっと可能性だけ
あの火曜木曜日の勉強会でも同じ質問が出て
質問があったんですよ
なんとかの勉強会かわかりませんけど
だからやっぱり人間にはカーと聞こえたらカラス
あちらの方でした 何さんでした？
そういうその時も言いましたけど
で 私は言ったのはやっぱりカーと言っただけではカラスではないということなんですね
ですから あのカーと聞いたらカラスというのは推測であって
100%正しいわけじゃないんですね
音と言った途端 もうこれは 100%
そうやって自分の中身を
自分の体と心を 100%の確実性で確認する
それが人の気持ちわかりませんからね
例えば嫌な顔をしているんだからといって怒っているわけでもないでしょうに
ニコニコと笑っているんだから
この人はすごい機嫌がいいと
そうじゃないんですよ
時々人殺したいぐらい怒りがあって
すごくニコニコ笑っている場合もありますからね
ですから 人のことはそんな簡単にわからない
でも自分のことだったらわかる
口で笑っていても 心では泣いてるんだよと
ということは 自分のものだったらわかりますね
それでもう最初は 60%でもいいんだけど
怒りが生まれたら怒りと嫉妬が生まれたら今は嫉妬があるんだと
悩みが生まれたら 今悩んでるんだと
雑念が生まれたら雑念しているんだと
妄想だったら今妄想しているんだと
今怠けているんだと 今は眠たがってるんだとかね
それで自分の世界を 内なる世界をちゃんと淡々と 100%の確実性で確認して確認して確認していく
そうすると自分というものはこの瞬間瞬間の出来事の連結でしょ
別に自分というものがいるわけじゃないんだから
我々はこの時間で この瞬間瞬間の出来事をまとめて
一つのロールして これが私と思っているだけで
それでこの客観的な観察法で
全部このこうやって伸ばしてみるんですね
伸ばすというかね 道を広げてみるんですね
広げてみたら このその瞬間
その瞬間で自分が何者
どんなことをしたんですかということが見えてくる
そこで自分というものはないということもわかってきますけどね
それでパターンができちゃうんですよ
ああ こういうパターンだなと
そのパターンがわかったら
次のステージがあるんです
他人のことも観察する
どんな観察の場合も お釈迦様はこの 3つのパターンでやってくださいと
まず内の観察する それは 100%でできるんです
それから他人のことも観察する
いわゆる外の世界も観察する
それは 100%でできないかもしれませんけど
できるだけもうたくさん確実性が高い方で
考える　 例えば自分の怒りは知ってる　だったらもう人が怒っていると
あ この人にも怒りがあると
と見る 話している時でもそれできますよ
時々人が私は楽しいですよと言っても
なんで楽しいのでしょうか？とか言ったら
それは楽しいわけじゃなくて怒りではないかと発見もできますよ
人をそうやって客観的に観察する
それちょっと 1番やらないと難しいんですけどね
まあこういうこと 例えば人の目に涙があるとしますね
見て あ、 あの人は悲しがっていると
悲しみがあると で
あらちょっと待ってくださいということになって
その人になんで泣いてるんでしょうか？とかね
聞いてみたりする そうすると私は泣いてるわけじゃなくて
目に塵が入っちゃって
かなり痛いんだと ああ
そうですかと それで その人には苦しみがあると
そういうふうに この自分は感じませんけどね
まあ 苦しみがあると調べてみて
でもできるだけ 100%の確実性で
そのいろんな人には その瞬間
その瞬間で何があるかと
例えば動物喧嘩する時でも
喧嘩はいつでも怒りってわけじゃないんだから
まあ小犬たちが喧嘩していると
ああ みんな喜んで遊んでいると
こちらに喜びがあると
それで大きな犬 オス同士でもう牙を見せて喧嘩すると
あ 怒りがあると  犬の中でもやっぱり高慢があるんだからね
力強い犬が私が偉いと
力弱い犬が私に礼をしなくちゃいけないんだと
その礼儀わからない もう弱い犬たちっていうのはかなりひどい目にあっちゃうんですよ
礼儀知ってるんだったら問題ないんだけど
強い犬見たら すぐもうお腹見せちゃうと
あるいはもうしゃがんでいると
もうわかりますね もうそうか
はいはい いいよということで終わっちゃいますけど
でないともう噛まれちゃうんですね
そこはその客観的に見る
こちらには高慢がある
私にも高慢もある 同じものをこの犬ちゃんに
ワンちゃんにもあると
そこで噛まれる犬がすごく怯えている
恐怖感があると 私にもそのいろいろ恐怖感があったケースがありましたと
私もこういう時 こういう時
恐怖感があったと 今こういうところで恐怖感があると
そうやってこの外の世界で
日常生活で生きていると
いろんなものと関係あるでしょうに
その時その時もその観察仕事をやっちゃうんですよ
外の世界で それでまあ
１週間  ２週間 あるいは １ヶ月
２ヶ月でも１年でもいいんですけど
やってみると なんかパターンがあるんじゃないかなと
みんなに これまた自分のパターンとも似ているんだと
って見えてきます 同じパターンだと
全く同じじゃなくて パターンのちょっと説明しにくいんですが
まあパターン違います
例えば私には怒り 怒り
怒り 怒り  100個ぐらいあって
それからもう落ち込み
落ち込み１０個ぐらいあって
それから喜び３個ぐらいあって
それそうかもしれません
私の場合は 犬の場合は楽しみ
楽しみ 楽しみ  100個ぐらいあって
それからもう怠け
怠けとか１０個ぐらいあった
そういうパターンかもしれません
でもそれは違いますけど
個人差ですけど 個人差がないのは
怒りの場合は対象に逆らったということ
嫌ということですね そこは犬にも私にも同じ
怒った時は だから怒りが同じ
怒りは何個生まれるかということは個人の世界
そこで恐怖感があるでしょ
恐怖感というのはもう自分の身にね
危険が迫った時なんですね
怖いと思うのは それも怒りです
仏教では怒りですけど
恐怖感として見えてますね
それであるものには恐怖と出ます
同じくある似ている 全く似ている現象に
ワンちゃんも恐怖を出すんですよ
だって自分の家に泥棒が入ろうとして
窓ガラスでもなんかで割れちゃうとすごい恐怖感で怯えるでしょうに
自分の命に危険が迫っているんでしょう
同じ法則で 小さな犬が大きな犬にやられちゃうと恐怖感を感じちゃうんですね
そうやってパターンがあるんだと
これ似ているんだと そこで３番目のステージに行くんです
３番目のステージっていうのは
対象にどのように反応するかと
見たものに受け取る反応
receiving と accepting という受け取る
あ どうぞ入ってくださいという反応だったら欲が生まれるんです
絵を見て ああ 綺麗な絵だなと思ったら欲が生まれるんです
それで見たものに拒絶する反応を出しちゃうと怒りになるんです
なんて醜い絵ですかと思ったら怒りなんですよ
そこで綺麗な絵だなという欲の世界でも
いろんな欲の種類があるんですよ
無数に だからものすごい欲望
やら欲しいぐらいの気持ちやら
楽しいぐらいのものやらね
もう死んでも欲しいという欲とかね
もありますね 怒りの場合も嫌ですよと
出て行けと言っちゃうと
もうちょっと強いでしょうね
憎しみもっと強いでしょうね
嫉妬 かなり強い怒りでしょうし
そこで瞋恚と呼ぶんですけど
もの激しい怒りもありますね
殺したいほど怒りがあるでしょう
時々 時々殺せない場合は自分でも殺してやるぞと自分を殺しちゃうんです
そうやって怒りにもいろいろ強弱と形が違っているものがあるので
それも見えてきます それはこの 3番目のステージなんですよ
この普遍的な真理を発見する
まず内の体を見る それから外の世界のことを見る
それでこのパターンを見つけて
普遍的な法則を見つけてみる
それが身に　手に入ったら
まあ人の気持ちなんかはすぐわかるんです
これから何するかと この人
だからいわゆる普遍的な宇宙的な法則は自分で取ったことになるんですね
そうなってくると 自分という自我意識が大体消えてます
これかなりの智慧なんです
だから自分という世界で落ち込んで
あの人怒ってるんだ あの人私のことを悪口言ってるんだって
それは精神的な病気なんですよ
自分がそう思ってるだけ
そうじゃなくて これはちゃんとした自己観察からスタートする智慧なんです
その智慧が出たら 人のことっていうのはもう手のひらの上のように分かるんですよ
本当は大したことないんですよ
みんなあるパターンで生きているんです
こんな個性だとか もう自分の世界
個人のとかいろいろ言うんだけど
何のこともないんです
人のプライバシーとかいろんなこと言うでしょ
何のこともない ただみんな同じパターンがあって
そのパターンの中でただ反応しているだけ
ですから この　それぐらい
そうすると この相手に対して自分が憎んだりすることできない
これは科学者の観察だから
例えば医学の先生ががんの研究するとしますね
それでネズミの耳にがんを植え付けたりとかね
犬の口にがん細胞を植えたりするでしょうに
ああ かわいいという気持ちでも
でもああ 汚いね この犬は
とかね よだれを垂らしたりとか
そういう気持ちないです
研究だから だからこの研究者っていうのは
きれいでも汚いとか そんな気持ちでいくわけじゃなくて
ちゃんと淡々と研究する世界だから
そうやってこの心の働きを客観的に観察する
観察して この普遍的な真理を自分で自分の手に取る
お釈迦様おっしゃっているんだけど
自分で実験していないんだから
自分のものになってないんです
まだまだ この実験してみると
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているその真理が自分のものになるんです
そういう人がすぐその人のパターンがわかるんですよ
この人はこんなパターンでいくんだと
大体怒りはどれぐらい生まれるか
割り当てまで見えてくるんですよ
この人はもう 3分怒ったらもう3秒は
喜んじゃうんだよと
またもう 30秒は落ち込んじゃうとか
そういうパターン見えてくるんですね
それは 1時間ごとではなくて
１日にどれぐらいかと  1週間
1ヶ月間でもう大体見えます
このパターン　だから人という概念はもう大体消えてしまいますけどね
だから本当はまあ 普遍的な真理として全部一切を理解する方法はあります
まず自分を理解することから始めなくちゃいけないんです
論理的に言えば 自分も宇宙のほんの一欠片
一部であって みんなも同じことであって
なんか大変なことがあるはずがないんです
自分にないものは他人にあるはずがないんです
他人にないものは自分にもあるはずがないんです
そういうふうなやり方で
この見方が どんな観察もその 3つやるんですよ
1番目はアッジャッタというんです
2番目バヒッダ 3番目両方合わせてアッジャッタバヒッダ
だから意味としてはアッジャッタというのは内というね
意味で　バヒッダというのは外という意味で
アッジャッタバヒッダっていうのは両方まとめたということは
普遍的に見るということなんですね
この四念処経なんか見ると
たとえ呼吸瞑想でもその三つで見るんですよ
まず自分の呼吸を観察する
それから生きるものは誰でも呼吸しているんだから
そのたびそのたび もうそれぞれもちゃんと観察してみる
それはもう簡単で難しくはないんですよ
それで普遍的な真理としても生きるということはそういう波動でしょうと
アメーバにしたっても
ゾウさんにしたっても
ミミズにしたっても 人間にしたっても
生きるものはただ同じことをやっているでしょうに
順番違いますけど 植物も同じことやってますけどね
植物だけ 自分の栄養は自分で作っているんだから
だからちょっとパターンが変わってるだけで
ちゃんと呼吸はしています
ただ それだけでしょうと
そんなもんでしょうと
それで秘密はありますか？私に人に知られて恥ずかしいってことはありますか？その呼吸については
で そうやってたくさんの瞑想法がありますけど
全部そういう風に３セットで見るんです
例えば感情を見るときでも
痛みとかね 気持ちいいとかいろいろ感情あるでしょうに
感情ではない感覚ですね
で 自分に痛みがあると
これ 人の痛みも この人にも痛みがあると見る
痛みということは 何か隠さないと恥ずかしいとか何かありますか？ないでしょうに
ただの痛みだから で それで普遍的なこと
痛みっていうのは 生き物が物に触れると生まれてくる感覚なんですよ
それで厳密に自分の心体を見てみると
体の感覚は全部痛みのみであるということがわかるんです
呼吸も痛みなんですよ
膨らんだら痛いんだから縮ませちゃうんです
お腹縮んだところで気持ち悪いんだから膨らませちゃうんです
立っていて疲れるんだから座るんです
座って疲れるんだから立つんですよ
黙ってて疲れるんだからしゃべるんですよ
しゃべって疲れるんだから黙ってるんです
だから心臓も同じで すべての1個1個の細胞もそういうふうに動いているんです
痛みで それで隠すことなんもないんです
別に それで私は痛みがあるのに
何か楽しみがある 何か人生に喜びがある
何か快楽がある 生きることは苦であるはずがないと
えらい勘違いしてるでしょ
それで楽しみを探していくでしょうに
追っていくでしょうに
犬猫も同じことなんですよ
アフリカのサバンナの動物でも
ものすごい過酷な環境なのに
とにかく歩く歩く 先には楽しみがあると
で 楽しみあるところから
あっちこっちからライオンにもやられちゃうし
虎にもやられたりとかいうこともありますけど
そういう風にこの自分を見て外を見て
それから普遍的な真理を見いだす
それでわかるようになります
他人の心 だからそうやって智慧がないならば
何もそういう訓練しないで
ああ あの人のことを任せておけばわかっているんだというのは
もう単なる誤解 というのは
ちょっとしたちゃんとした科学的な訓練をしないで言ったら
もうそれはもう当てにならない
それはただ自分の主観で
自分の傲慢の判断なんですね
あの人は信頼できないんだとか
あの人はちょっとすごい信頼できるんだとかね
あの人はちょっと狂暴だとか
もうまあわかってるもんだよとかね
それはちょっと傲慢でよくない
この場合の判断ではない
この場合は研究結果だけ
それで人の心はわかる
人の心わかると その人
まあ何の問題なく人間と一緒に生活できる
それからこの普遍的な法則をわかった人はこれ知るんですよ
この世の中で偶然なことはない
突発的な　 突然人が人殺したと
なんかわからない なんであの人　人殺したんでしょうかとか
ありえないんです すべて因果法則ですよ
ちゃんと原因があって結果が出てくるんです
まあ 例えばこの単三電池 1個持ってきて
この電気を一つ光もを照らそうと思ってもできるわけないでしょ
もし私は単三電池 １個でこれにつなげて
これぐらい光を出しちゃうと
これは突然で不思議で
大変なんですね そういうことは絶対ありえないんです
すべて因果法則なんです
ですから なんで人のことを読めないと言うんでしょうかね
因果法則さえわかれば
みんなそのパターンで動いています
はい まあ 次残りはできるだけ早く言います
まだ半分以上残ってますけど
ですから 自分のことをわかってくれっていうことだけはやめた方がいいんです
世渡りしたければ その代わりにもうちょっと知識的になって
自分と他人のことをわかってもらう
自分の気持ち ちゃんと子供がわかってくれって思うのではなくて
自分の気持ちも子供の気持ちも両方まとめてわかってもらえば
なんとかうまく生きていられるんです
だから親が叫ぶんだったら
子供に親の気持ちをわかってくれとかね
それでうまくいかないんですよ
わかりたくないんだから
わかったらやられちゃいますから
お母さんの気持ちわかっちゃったら
子供はお母さん言うことやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
まあですから そういうことと違って
やっぱりこの何ですか
まあ自分と他人の気持ちをわかってもらえばいいんです
例なんですけど このお釈迦様がこの中道的な生き方でしたから
一度も一度もというのはおかしいんですけど
生き方の中で自分を強調しなかったんです
自分を強調しちゃうと
私はこういうもの 私はこういうものと言っちゃうと
うまく仏教を語ることできなくなるんです
でも 言わなくちゃいけない時は言います
私はもう煩悩はないんだと
悟ってはいるんだと 一応チャレンジしてゴールに達しているんだということは
まあそれ必要な時は言うんだけど
そればっかり看板に出して説法したわけじゃないんです
あっちこっちお釈迦様歩いた時は誰もわからない
何？誰ですか？と ある場所でお釈迦様が ある王様なんですけど
国を捨てて出家しようと思って北の方に向かってきたんですね
なんかお釈迦様にも心残り入っちゃって
あの人は王にはもうならないというかね
なんか危ないというかね
で やっぱり道も遠いし
王様だからね そんな一人でこそこそと宮殿を出て出家したっても
家出したってもね 生活できるわけじゃないしね
だからお釈迦様心配して迎えに行ったんです
途中で会った方がいいと
歩いて歩いて まあお釈迦様の方がかなり毎日歩いていたんだからね
歩いていったら ある日夜もう誰でも行者たちが集まる場所があって
そこでお釈迦様いて その場所を管理する人に聞いたんです
私は今日 夜 ここに泊まってもいいんでしょうかと言ったら
うーん まあ私は反対ではないんだけど
でも先にもう一人の行者が入ってるんだと
ですから その人に聞かないと
私に何も言えません と言ったら
お釈迦様は中に入って
その行者からね 行者に聞くんです
私も今日夜ここで泊まってもいいんでしょうかと
そしたらどうぞどうぞ場所あるんだから
夜泊まってくださいと そしたらお釈迦様は自分の衣を置いて
鉢も置いて座っているんですね
いる時はちょっと挨拶とか
ちょっとしゃべるんですよ
しゃべるんだけど まあ　あなたはどこから来る人？と言ったら
私は南の方の何とかの国の王子で
本当はもう家出して もう王はやりたくないんだからね
家出してもう出家したんだと
で あなたはなんで出家したんでしょうかね
誰の先生？誰が先生でしょうかと
いえもう 北の方ではブッダ
釈迦牟尼仏陀という人がいて
悟っていて説法するんだというすごい話がありまして
私はその先生のところに行って修行したいんだと
あんた見たことありますか？と
いや 見たこともない 話を聞いたこともないんだと
言って それで夜 お釈迦様は寝ませんからコソコソコソコソしゃべってるんですよ
世の中のことどうですかと
人生ってそうですね やっぱり王になったってまあ苦労しか何もないとか
そういう話していたでしょうね
それで夜明けになってくると
あの人は悟ってるんです
それで気づくんですよ
これがお釈迦様やと どういう
どういう性格ですか？それ自分を言わないんですよ
夜明けになって悟りをひらいた途端
まあそれは仏教の弟子たちから説法を聞いても悟りますけど
やっぱりこれなんとか違うと
で 気づいちゃって で 聞いたんですね
まあ本当は先生がお釈迦様ではないかと聞いたら
まあそうなんですけどと
言って もうなんて失礼なことをしたかと
自分が友達の言葉で呼んだんだと
ものすごい失礼なことをしましたから
どうか許してくださいと言って
その場で出家して まあ別に悪いことしたわけじゃないんだからね
お釈迦様帰っちゃうんですよ
もうあの人はまあそこら辺で生活すればいいと
もう悟ったんだから だからお釈迦様はその人はそんなに苦労はできない
北インドまで行って 寒いところでね
生活できるかもわからない
まあ王様だからね そんな苦労したわけでもないしね
ですから そこら辺も心配して
もう面倒見てあげたんだけど
やっぱりちゃんと自分を出さないで語った
そういうケースありますと
いくつかも 自分を強調しないということ
強調しちゃうとうまくいかないんですよ
それでお釈迦様に時々こういう質問をするんですよ
あなたは何を教えてる人ですかね？あなたの教えはなんでしょうか？
何でしょうか？と聞いたら
お釈迦様はこう言うんですよ
ちょっと待ってくださいと
それはあなたにわかるわけじゃないと
あなたが何を知ってるんでしょうかと
私に言ってください あなたに何か疑問があったら
問題があったら なんとか何かあったらそれは聞いてくださいと
私が何知ってるかと聞くなよと
その時でも お釈迦様は自分を理解してくれという立場じゃないんでしょ
あなた 相手のことを理解しようとする
だからお釈迦様の行動はうまくいった
時々このバラモン人とかね
このすごい社会的なインテリ中のインテリだと
もう論争 争論とか まあそれは専門家だと言ってものすごく自慢している
この知識を職業にしている人々いましたから
そういう人々は時々お釈迦様にも質問を出すんですよ
あなたの教えは何でしょうか？とかね
出したケースあります
その場合は 本人はただもう知識
職業だから 別に相手の気持ちを知りたいとか
もう何もないんですよ
ただちょっと貶したいだけ
その時 お釈迦様は私の教えはこういう教えですよと言うんです
でも その場合は一度も理解したことがないんです
相手が 例えばWhat is your teaching?あなたの教えは何ですか？と
この知識人が聞いたならば
お釈迦様は答えますけど
その答えがその知識人には理解できない
それもお釈迦様は計算してするんです
そんな簡単に理解できないんだということを
だから相手はもう聞いてもまずかったということで
わからないんだけど また質問することもできないし
自分の立場もありますから
黙って帰るんです  そういう経典もあります
一応今言えませんが それからこのお釈迦様の中道的な言い方っていうのは
各人にあって その人の気持ち
理解 考え方 生き方 それをその人から聞いて
それを整理してあげるんです
それを直してあげるんだ
正してあげるんです その人に新しいものを強引に入れるのではなくて
その人の生き方を整理して調整して解脱できるようにする
それが仏教なんです だから仏教っていうのは何でしょうかと聞いても
中道ですよというしかないんですけど
結構複雑で大きいんです
いろんなところで いろんなそれぞれ人に
日本で何説法というんですか？あれは対機説法でしたっけ
え？対機説法なんとかって言うんですけど
それ自体大変なことなんです
それが本物の説法なんですよ
だって私が例えばスリランカ人で
自分の好き嫌い 自分の生き方
皆様に言ったっても もう興味ないとかね
関係ないとか ああそうですかというぐらいでしょうに
それで説法にも何もならない
自分の意見を出すことが
ですから 本当の説法になるのは
相手が何に悩んでいるか
どんな生き方をしているんですか？相手の人生の目的は何でしょうかと
その各個人の世界なんですね
その世界はちょっと調整してあげて
変なところはちょっと取ってあげて
じゃあこういう風にすればいいんでしょうか
それで本人がよくわかるんですよ
自分の生き方だから それで解脱体験するんですね
だから我々仏教の弟子たちも
その技を身につけなくちゃいけない
自分の意見を言っても
もうあまりうまくいかないんですね
それで その場合は 聞いた人が自分を貶されたという気持ちは全くないんです
だって 自分の意見をよく聞いていただいたんだから
人の不思議なところというのは
自分のことをわかってくれるとえらい機嫌がいいんですよ
ああ 理解したんだなとかね
私の気持ちもよくわかったんですね
あの人はすごい偉い人やと
そういうことだから お釈迦様が相手の話を聞くでしょうね
それでその聞いた人が
たとえ違う宗教の人であろうとも
すごい気持ちいいんです
よく自分のことをわかってくれてるんだと
それわかったところでお釈迦様はちょっとここら辺はどうでしょうか
こういう風に考えたら
ここら辺はこういう風に考えたらどうでしょうかとかね
相手が私は永遠に天国に行きたいんだと言っても
でも永遠の天国があるかどうか定かじゃないでしょうね
ですから 今心の安定を作った方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
言うと永遠に天国はないよと言ってないんだからね
あ なるほど そういえばそうだ
そうだなと いうことで悟りに行っちゃうでしょうね
だから相手 この相手が他宗教の人であろうと
何のことなく すごい気持ちもよく
プライドを傷ついたこともなく
また目的にも達する ただ
この生ぬるい仲良くじゃないんですよ
あなたはXという宗教ですか？私はYという宗教
じゃあ握手しましょうと
そんなそれでどっちでもないんだから
そういう生ぬるいとことでもないんですよ
このXという宗教はどういう宗教でしょうかとかね
Yは置いといて ああ そうでしょうか
なるほど なるほどとよく理解して
それからずるずるとそちらのね
どうせ矛盾があるんだから
人間の考え方だから その矛盾とそれから出てくる苦しみを教えてあげて
それからこういう風にちょっと直せばいかがでしょうかと
言うと 本人知らないうちにもう仏教
実践しているんです ブッダの教え
ブッダの教えなんですね
だから世渡りといえばお釈迦様でしょうに
その生き方にお釈迦様はある言葉使ってます
パーリ語でアパンナカというんです
アパンナカというパーリ語の
これ専門用語ですけど
アパンナカっていうのは
この疑問成り立たない生き方
反論成り立たない生き方なんです
で 偏見だったら反論成り立つんですよ
それで相手と話し合って
この相手の話にある矛盾見せるだけのことで
それでだからあなたはこういうことを信じなさいと言っちゃうと反論成り立つんです
だから最初から信じるものなんもないんだよと
自分持ってる考え方捨てればそれだけですよと
という後になってそういう話になるんです
そこで自分の意見強調しようとすると
お釈迦様は結構苦労しました
皆様ご存知のこの初めの説法
初転法輪 この初転法輪というのは自分の友達５人に言おうとしたんですよ
これ家来なんですよ
５人とも それで自分の過去
過去のね 在家の時の家来でもありましたし
出家した時でも自分のお世話もしてくれたし
だから悟りを開いた時は
まあ教えてあげるぞと
私の悟りを教えてあげると言ったところで断られたんです
あのお釈迦様も だからその場合は
俗的に言えば お釈迦様が私の心わかってくれと
私は悟りましたよと そしたら 誰が信じるんですか？そんなことを
誰が信じるのよ あんただらしないんだと
あの家来の５人の比丘たちが
言ったら お釈迦様そうじゃないんだよと
私は本当に悟りましたから
話聞きなさいと そしたらまた断られるんですよ
あなたは王子で 苦行もできなくて
途中でやめて よくご飯食べて
今体もちゃんとできていてね
あんたもうただ堕落しただけでしょうと
信じませんと ３回目言ったら３回も同じ反応
聞かない それでお釈迦様は最終手段は出しちゃったんですよ
では聞きますけど 私はのことはあなた方はずっと子供の頃から知ってるでしょ
私は生まれてから一度でも嘘をついたこと
人を騙したことありますかと
それで考えれば なるほど
それはなかったと 一度も嘘をついたこと
人を騙したことはなかった
だから私の話を聞きなさい
やっと苦労して説法する機会をいただいたんですよ
だから自分の意見を言おうとすると
お釈迦様さえもこういう目に遭いますよ
私の気持ちわかってくれと思ったら
だから皆さんはやめた方がいいんです
それからお釈迦様はそれをちゃんと研究して
自分の意見を出して争うということをしなかったんですよ
涅槃に入る時まで それから全部対話形式で相手の質問に答える
相手の問題に合わせる
時々弟子たちができた時は
私は昔も今も苦と苦の苦しみをなくす方法しか教えませんよとおっしゃった時もありますけど
比丘たち以外は自分の意見は出せないということ
それにこれでポイントだけ言います
この人生に勝ちたければ
ワンポイントがあります
勝つ方法は相手を負かさないことなんです
で その気持ちだったらもう勝てません
勝つということは勝ち負けではないんですよ
自分の気持ち 自分の努力が成功することなんです
それはみんな誤解して
ライバル意識で競争意識で
誰かが負けて誰かが勝つんだよと
だから必勝宣言までして
この試験勉強する人々とかね
何の必勝宣言とかわかりませんだけど
勉強すればいいんですけど
で このライバルがいるんだと
負けるべき 負かすべき
負かすというんですか
相手がいるんだと思ったら
自分は決してうまくいかないんですよ
ですから 勝ち負けの世界ではなくて
この世界というのは自分の能力
自分の努力を実ってほしい
それだけのことなんです
ですから 相手に対してライバル意識を消しちゃえば
うまくいきます 何でも
だから怒りは良くない
ライバル意識は良くない
競争は良くない で 説明する時間はない
それから怒りやら嫉妬やら精神的な混乱やら
いろいろ感情が出た時は逃げてください
その時はもう自分を離れて一人になるしか方法ないんです
それでなきゃ どれぐらい怪我するかわからないんです
人と喋ったり 仕事をしたり
行動したり 社会に出る場合は
いつでも機嫌が良くて
ニコニコと頭もしっかり鋭く回る時はもうやって
でも波があるんだから
時々まあ機嫌が悪くなるし
もうわけもないんだけど
ただ怒っているとかね
その時はもう行動しないで下がる
その時は休むということ
いわゆる自分の弱みを見せない
汚い言葉で言えば 弱みを見せないということなんです
弱みはみんなにあるんです
そこは出たらもうすぐ社会から隔離する
自分で自分も それですごい
まあ機嫌が良くなったら
まあ社会に入る ということで
これ悪い言葉だったら覚えやすいんだから
弱みを見せないと だから弱みを見せちゃうと
結局自分が不幸になるでしょうに
やられますでしょうに
だからそれは弱点とは言えませんね
それから 例えば商売なんかの商談する時は
大変 みんなもう精神的にストレスかかっちゃうでしょうに
うまくいかない この 決断は出してくれないとかね
あれはやり方が良くない
仏教的じゃないんです
貪瞋痴でやるんだから
ですから 真面目にこの商売っていうのは 2つのからくりでしょうに
A が売る  B が買うとかね
だから買う  B が損しちゃうと商売じゃないんです
あるいは売る A が損しちゃうと商売じゃないんで
だから商売っていうのは
A も B も得しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 前に言ったようなことで
自分がある商売組織を作ったならば
それで儲かるという目的ではなくて
この商売はどれぐらい社会に人類に役に立つかと
それで頭を動かしちゃうんです
役に立つようにするんだ
人の役に立つようにするんだと
それはすごく大事なことね
それから 例えば 2人で商談するでしょ？自分の会社の品物を買ってくださいと相手の会社の社長に言う
その時はメインポイントは何なのかというと
買う相手にメリットは何ですか？と
それが自分で研究して
相手にあるメリット 相手はどれぐらい得しますか
それを言うんですよ 大体私はいろいろ話を聞くと
まあちょっと大した商談なんか聞いたことないんだけど
ちょっと聞いてくると
自分の利益 自分の そうすると私は損しますよとか
そんな話になっちゃうんですよ
それはちょっと無理ですよとかね
これぐらいお金かかってるんだよと
この品物を作るためにと
あれだったら私は商売
商売やりたくない そういう人と
その人にいくらお金かかったんだからといって関係ないでしょうに
私は例えば封筒 100個ぐらい作って売ろうとする
私にはそれには例えば500円かかったとします
そうすると私は 600円で売ろうとする
それで相手が あのね 封筒 100枚は 600円で売れません
せいぜい 250円ですよ
と言ったら 私はそんなこと言ったっても
これは 500円もかかっているんだからと言っても
成り立たないでしょうに
だから自分にお金がこれぐらいかかったということは
このビジネスディスカッションの場合は平気で言うんですよ
あれでダメなんです 自分には高いお金をかけないように
作品 商品を作るのは自分のプロの世界の仕事でしょうに
お金かかったと言ったらもう下手でしょうに
だからそんな話ではなくて
これ買った相手の会社がどれぐらい利益がありますかと
どれぐらいメリットがありますかと
相手の会社の商売はどれぐらいうまくいくんでしょうかと
その辺を研究して言えば
まあ 5分で終わりますよ
商売は まあわかりましたと
だから基本的なことは同じ
自分が儲かる哲学ではなくて
人類の役に立つ哲学なんです
商売の場合はそのやり方で仏教的なやり方なんです
で それからこの世の中でいろんな意見がありましてね
ぶつかるでしょうに 意見の相違点がありすぎて喧嘩になる
戦争にもなる 今も地球であっちこっち人殺して殺して殺してもただの意見違いだけでしょ
それどうしましょうかね
それが単なる意見違いじゃないんですよ
感情なんです だからどうにもならないんですよ
私は偉いと思ったら感情でしょうに
だからいくら理屈を言っても自分の気持ちは変わりません
私は綺麗だと思っちゃったら
それ感情でしょうに 例えば可愛いという考え方というのは感情でしょ
犬可愛い 猫可愛いとみんな思ってるし
時々猿も飼って可愛いと思ったりするでしょうに
蛇も飼ってる人がいるでしょ
可愛い可愛いと トカゲも飼ってる人々いるでしょうに
可愛いと言ってるでしょうに
ある日 テレビでナマケモノも飼ってる人も見たんだけど
その人すごく可愛いと言ってますよ
だから理屈じゃないんですよ
感情です だからこの意見相違
のことでトラブルが起こるのはこの感情なんですよ
ですから もう感情で喋ったりするとかはやめた方がいいんです
意見違いは決して悪いことじゃないんです
論理的だったら とにかくやりたいということは問題なんです
一人が北海道へ行きたい
一人が沖縄へ行きたいと言っても
まあだからお父さんがこの子供二人はどうやって連れていけばいいんでしょうかね
だからそれはすごい困るんですよ
子供というのは感情で
私は北海道に行きたいんだと
もし子供がちょっとした理屈的に
なぜ北海道か なぜ沖縄かと
私は一回そういうチャレンジ出してみたんです
子供に ちゃんと論理的に計算してみなさいと
親に怒られたんだけど
で 言ったらそれなりに研究したんです
子供は自分の意見を通して欲しいんだから
それでまあいくら何でもお金かかりますから
じゃあお金も計算しましょうと
入場料はいくらでしょうかとかね
そこまで行く電車代とかね
それはどれぐらいでしょうかとかね
そうすると安い方がいいでしょうとかね
何のことなく同じ意見に持ってきたんですよ
すごい近い意見 やっていたんだけど
結局感情は除いて知恵に持っていったら
論理に持っていったら意見違いっていうのは結論出ますよ
だから世の中の問題は感情でいくんだから
屁理屈で非論理的で無茶苦茶なんです
たとえ大国であろうか
小国であろうが関係ないんですね
まあ それからまだ全部残り
そこに残りは置いておいて
最後にこれ言いたいんです
結局仏教が言いたいのは
まあみんな仲間であるという生き方で生きてくださいと
人類っていうのは誰でももう仲間であって
ライバルでも何でもないと
その生き方で生きていれば
まあ 世の中でうまく生きていられます
ただ その最後のその言葉だけでも覚えておいてください
皆仲間であると それだったら生きていられます
それは慈しみのまあ 考え方なんです
どうもありがとうございます
[applause]